in 1990 the ussr already having a
difficult time started to fall apart in
earnest first it was lithuania who left
followed by all of these states until
december 1991 when only the russian
belarusian and kazak soviet socialist
republics remained belarus seceded on
the 10th of december and two days later
russia the main component also left
leaving only the kha'zix not just in the
ussr but effectively as the ussr for
four whole days until it opted to secede
too which raises an obvious question why
why was kazakhstan the last to leave the
ussr well as the soviet union was
falling apart there was a struggle for
power between mikhail gorbachev
president of the soviet union who wanted
to preserve the ussr and boris yeltsin
the chairman of the russian supreme
soviet who wanted an independent
non-communist russia yeltsin was in the
process of dismantling the ussr's
ministries and bureaucracies and was in
contact with the belarusian and
ukrainian leaders whilst doing so and
these discussions ended with the
bellavasia records this repealed the
founding document of the ussr between
the three countries and also created a
success estate the cis the commonwealth
of independent states in the kazakh
soviet republic this caused anger since
unlike ukraine they were still a member
of the soviet union and nobody had asked
them for their opinion furthermore there
were a lot of legal questions as to
whether these three were allowed to
dissolve a sovereign state or not the
kazakh leader nur sultan nazarbayev was
sent to moscow by the other central
asian states to seek a compromise you
see whilst all except that kha'zix had
left the ussr many still wanted close
cooperation with russia the problem was
that their leaders were elected within
the soviet framework and abolishing the
ussr may have destroyed their legitimacy
as such they tried to moderate between
yeltsin's independence and gorbachev's
return to the ussr as it was before this
never happened and on the 12th of
december russia left the ussr and only
the kha'zix remained so what happened
during this time well the kha'zix were
doing two things negotiating with russia
to allow central states into the new cis
which was hoped would be closer to the
ussr in its operation than a trading
block and also creating the framework to
be an independent country just in case
everything fell apart this included
changing the kazakh soviet socialist
republic's name to the republic of
kazakhstan but again it was still a
technicality since it was the sole
remaining state in the ussr so how did
things like foreign relations work did
kazakhstan have to represent the ussr at
the united nations or have to take on
its foreign obligations well no the
ussr's president and leader were still
in the same moscow office as before and
so all of the international discussions
going on at the time were done there
gorbachev was still the president of the
ussr if it still existed that was and
things were moving so quickly very few
people knew exactly what was going on
internationally many countries
recognized the independence of russia
and belarus from the soviet union and
thus tacitly they acknowledged that
kazakhstan was still a part of it that
said nobody cared and everybody knew
that the soviet union was effectively
finished and there was nothing that the
kazakhs could have done about it which
is why four days after russia left
kazakhstan did the same it wasn't that
they were holding out or trying to take
on the ussr's mantle it was just a vain
hope that by remaining in the soviet
union kazakhstan would maintain a good
relationship with gorbachev whose role
in the future was an unknown nazarbayev
was a close friend of the president and
similarly wanted to preserve the union
but when it became clear that this
wasn't going to happen kazakhstan did
the same as everyone else and they
formally left the ussr ten days later to
formalize its dissolution the leaders of
the newly independent states met in the
kazakh capital and formerly declared the
ussr didn't buried with russia becoming
its formal successor state
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons james
bisonette kelly money maker skye
chappelle corso wolff jerry lamdin
jordan longley adam stalter marcus
arsenault y and hockey spencer lightfoot
rod d martin words about books podcast
captain cydog gustav swan marvin castell
common yoon winston k wood boogie wiggly
daniel to be in miss izzette matthew
shipley aaron the white corey turner the
mcwhopper alex schwinn anthony beckett
copper tone maggie patzkowski schwennin
spinning three plates and charles the
first